yippee-kay-yay V lovers I'm John and in
this video I'm revealing the frozen to
deleted scenes that completely changed
the end of the movie including a
heartbreaking message from honor and
Elsa's parents and an awesome song for
Kristoff that we never got to see frozen
- took some dark turns however the
movie's original ending was going to be
even darker with the destruction of
arendelle Castle and even the possible
death of Elsa at the end of frozen to
honor makes a momentous decision on how
to restore peace to the lands we have to
break it down but her no will be flooded
she provokes the earth Giants into
destroying the dam which causes a huge
tidal wave that's about to engulf
arendelle until a reanimated Elsa
arrives and creates a giant ice barrier
to stop it
however a deleted scene on the blu-ray
now shows that in an earlier version of
the movie Elsa wasn't there to stop the
tsunami which went on to destroy
arendelle Castle and probably flooded
much of the kingdom the deleted scene
takes places honor Elsa and Kristoff
assess what to do in the aftermath of
the devastation caused by the flood will
rebuild the castle knew no secrets no
deceit new rules even this original
ending would have been a little darker
as a consequences of arendelle's
betrayal of the North Ultra would have
had a much greater impact on the kingdom
the art of frozen - Burke also gives
more details on what happened afterwards
in the original ending explaining that
the castle would have been rebuilt in a
combination of the North Ultra and
arendelle Ian styles in this alternate
ending honor also says she'll do away
with the old lies and secrets and create
brand new rules that last point is
likely a reference back to another
deleted scene in which honor and Elsa
discover a hidden room in the castle and
inside they uncover secret books and
journals belonging to their mother
these next pages are in English but also
North altar in Norse elder Ian but that
language is forbidden why wouldn't
mother know it or dare use it it sounds
like the repression of North ultra
culture in arendelle was even more
extensive than we saw in the film and
now she's aware of both this and her own
mixed heritage it's clear that in the
alternate ending Queen on a plan to
abolish this type of discrimination
and people now connected my love there's
another part to this original ending in
which Elsa uses her magic for honor to
bring back a memory of her parents
revealing just how highly they thought
of their younger daughter I want to show
you something darling I've been thinking
it might be time to tell Anna about Elsa
I can't bear keeping her shut out
anymore she's maturing now she can be
responsible it's not Anna
I'm worried about what if we let them
get close again and the feelings are too
much for Elsa joy brings her powers out
strongly as fear but if anyone can find
a way to help her it's honor she might
be right about that there's not much
that girl can't do her love could hold
up the world lucky for the world okay
we'll tell her when we return thank you
so much for that they believed in you
Anna
and so do I this scene was meant to
address the idea that honor has always
felt insecure about her parents decision
not to tell her about Elsa's powers and
it could have been a beautiful moment
that boosted her belief in herself
setting her up even better to become
queen of arendelle on top of that one
Elsa tells honor they believed in you
Anna and so do I the cutscene would have
mirrored perfectly what honor said to
Elsa earlier in the film I believe in
you Elsa more than anyone or anything
this deleted scene may have also gone
some way to address some people's
criticisms from the first movie about
ignored and Oona's parenting skills and
the decision to keep the sisters
separated from each other another big
change to the film's finale was that
originally it wasn't going to include
Kristoff proposing to honor indeed
Kristoff almost had a radically
different character arc in frozen 2
which started with his proposal to honor
happening early in the movie rather than
at the very end in earlier versions of
the movie Kristoff had an elaborate
grand proposal and saw
planned for honor in the castle gardens
which then turned into a charming Joette
for the couple so you're a lord now yeah
and here we are is it hot out here I
don't know um but I think it's romantic
is it well I thought kind of I mean yeah
and here we are in it I'm feeling very
romantic because it is romantic and I
guess I I wanted to ask you something
yes I mean okay why is this so hard
this is hard I'm sorry I didn't know no
no no it's not you hey what do you think
the odds are that he turns out to be a
deranged murderer and tries to kill you
like the last guy he almost married it
there are lots of intriguing moments and
details in this deleted scene and song
such as the fact that Christoph is now a
lord how its honour who ends up actually
popping the question an Olaf Savage joke
to Elser about whether Christoph will
turn out like Prince Hans the scene is
obviously a lot of fun and full of much
more spectacle than Kristoff sweet and
simple proposal in the final film honor
you are the most extraordinary person
I've ever known
I love you with all I am will you marry
me but ultimately the filmmakers have
said that they decided to take the idea
of Kristoff struggling with proposing to
honor and extend it over the whole film
instead Christoph's original arc through
the rest of the movie had him keeping
secrets from fauna about how he was
unhappy with his new position in
arendelle Ian high-society I'll go into
more details about that in my other
frozen to deleted scenes video now if
arendelle castle was destroyed in the
original ending for frozen - it
indicates that Elsa wasn't resurrected
in time to save the kingdom or as some
rumors for early test screening suggest
there's a version of the ending in which
Elsa never came back to life in the
actual movie after Elsa and freezes she
falls into the depths of the icy water
beneath at a Harlin and if you look
closely you can see the knock looking on
concept art from the art of frozen -
book shows the water spirit lifting the
unconscious
also from the water in a deleted scene
that might imply that Elsa didn't make
it and there's a moment from the secret
room deleted scene I mentioned earlier
that could support the theory that
Disney were considering killing off Elsa
I can find no record of a human with
power like hers but for the ancient
myths with their tragic feats there's
also something strange about the final
epilogue scene in arendelle in the scene
honor and bells a statue in tribute to
her mother and father but Elsa isn't
there to share the moment and the
earlier part of the scene feels like it
was originally going to be Ana's
coronation day given the very formal
green gown cape and crown she's wearing
presenting Her Majesty Queen Anna of
arendelle
[Music]
and just how dressed up Kristoff Olaf
and Sven are again if this was
originally Ana's coronation day then it
seems a little out of character for Elsa
to miss her sister's special moments
given how close they are and even if the
scene was always meant to be just a
statue unveiling for their parents it
still feels slightly amiss for Elsa not
to be there still ultimately it seems
like Elsa remaining dead at the end of
the movie would have been an unlikely
decision for Disney given just how
popular she is most they might have
contemplated reviving her in a
post-credits scene or perhaps teasing
her resurrection in a third movie Byron
end credits ting or some other hint but
even that feels too much for an animated
Disney film given a third movie could be
up to 6 years away more probable is that
in the original ending Elsa wasn't going
to recover quite so quickly so after the
knock pulled an unconscious Elsa from
the water we would have been led to
assume she was dead this would have been
followed by arendelle being hit by the
wave destroying the castle then in the
aftermath Elsa would finally have come
back to life this ending would have been
more impactful and darker given the
destruction in arendelle and Elsa
remaining dead for longer than she did
in the final movie we've also got many
other deleted scenes in frozen - that
would have changed other parts of the
story massively I'll be going into more
detail about the castles secret room ohh
laughs amazing deleted song and the
alternate
into the unknown in my next video you
can tap to watch that here as soon as
it's ready or follow the link in the
video description and if you'd like to
see even more of the concept art and
amazing behind-the-scenes details I
discussed in this video be sure to take
a look at the art of frozen to book
links are also in the video description
below so do you like any of these
alternate endings and deleted scenes for
frozen - and how do you feel about the
ending we did get four Elser and honor
comment with your thoughts below if you
enjoyed this and a share alike a hugely
appreciated tapleft for my full frozen -
playlist or tap write for another video
you're sure to like thanks for watching
and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers